JUST, BE QUIET, PLEASE.
HE SO MUCH FOR COMING ON,
APPRECIATE IT.
WELL, ONE GOAL THAT HAS BEEN IN
PROGRESS FOR A LONG TIME AMONG
ACTIVISTS IS BEING PURSUED WITH
GUSTO DURING THIS SHUTDOWN THAT
IS THE PLAN TO EMPTY THE
NATION’S PRISONS.
RECENTLY CALIFORNIA FEDERAL
JUDGE ORDERED IMMIGRANTS TO BE
RELEASED FROM DETENTION IF THEY
ARE MEDICALLY "VULNERABLE,"
WHICH BY THE WAY, WOULD DESCRIBE
MOST OF THE COUNTRY AT THIS
POINT.
ONE BENEFICIARY OF THAT ORDER
WAS A MAN CALLED MARTIN VARGAS.
HE WAS RELEASED FOR HAVING
DIABETES AND HEPATITIS C.
HE IS A SEX OFFENDER.
HE’S GUILTY OF CHILD MOLESTATION
MOLESTATION, LEWD ACTS WITH A
MINOR.
ANOTHER DIABETIC IMMIGRANT WAS
CONVICTED DESPITE A CONVICTION
FOR CHILD ABUSE SO PROUDLY THAT
A STANDARD NOW.
UNTIL WE HAVE A VACCINE FOR
CORONAVIRUS, AND WHO KNOWS WHEN
THAT WILL BE, WE HAVE TO POLICE
CHILD MOLESTERS AS LONG AS THEY
HAVE DIABETES.
MEANWHILE, PEOPLE ARE BEING
THREATENED WITH JAIL FOR GOING
OUTSIDE WITH OUT PERMISSION.
USE AUTHORITIES IN FLORIDA ARE
REST MINISTER HAVING A CHURCH
SERVICE.
THEY PUT THE CHRISTIANS IN
PRISON, THEY LET THE CHILD
MOLESTERS OUT.
OH, IN VIRGINIA YOU SAW A
SHOPKEEPER IN PRISON.
HE’S THERE WITHOUT BAIL FOR THE
CRIME OF DEFENDING HIMSELF
AGAINST BURGLARS.
BY THE WAY, HE HAS DIABETES TOO.
HE JUST COLLAPSED FROM IT.
THAT IS PROGRESSIVE PARADISE.
THEY SHOULDN’T HAVE WANTED WANT